[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISABELLE OLSSON:
[? Ovah ?] came up to me
and he said, just make it
comfortable and beautiful.
It freaked me out a
little bit, because what
they showed me was this.
I thought, I have a big
challenge in front of me.
For me, the most
important thing was,
how can we really reduce
this to its very essence?
And everything that's
not necessary goes away.
This is really high
tech, but my biggest goal
was to make it look simple.
When you have a very
big problem to solve,
you need to find
a couple of ideas,
and then really make them shine.
We had the optics that
was this, and then we
had a big board like this.
And I couldn't stand the idea
of some weird transition.
I came up with
the idea of hiding
the board behind the frame.
So from this view, it looks
like, here's the frame,
and here's this thing, and
it's separated and it's clean.
But the board actually goes
all the way to up to this edge.
This was such a simple idea, but
it kind of defined the product.
The second thing was be
really, really light.
One of the goals was this needs
to weigh less than 65 grams.
And I was like,
that's impossible.
These were 150 grams-- and I'm
obsessed with weight by now.
I'll always have a
little scale on my desk.
And as soon as we have a new
prototype, I put it there.
And it's like
Christmas every time,
because the weight
keeps on reducing.
The latest prototype
weighs 43 grams.
The Nexus phone is actually
heavier than three of these.
The most important part
of designing is prototype.
This one was before
my time, but-- yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
After I had done the
design, I came up
to one of the software
engineers and showed it to him,
and he was like, no way.
Now I need to program,
because I want
to make an experience
as beautiful as this.
It's not only the device.
People charge the device.
How is that experience?
You want to take it with you.
Well, you need a case for that.
How does all those
things come together?
We focus on trying to solve
problems and always simplify.
And then, in the end,
you can get somewhere.
But I think the most
important thing is just
not to feel overwhelmed.
Because if you really are
trying to do something new,
it's going to be really,
really, really, hard.
One of the most
important things when
designing completely new
products that people have never
seen before is, is
this really needed?
Is this button really needed?
If you make it work with the
bare minimum, you're golden.
That's what you have to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]